[Music]
calamari at his pro day workout on
wednesday
only through didn't run got on the scale
but that was it got weighed and went out
and threw the ball to his former
teammates chris we were talking about
this a little bit earlier look the guy
can throw the guy can do it all the only
knock on him is he's not six two six
three six four and if we've learned one
thing over the last 20 years in the nfl
it's so what yeah if you can throw the
ball if you can move you can play even
if you're not six feet tall yeah exactly
right and so what because these kids
have had so many reps before this time
they're used to seeing through the lanes
or having to play as a shorter
quarterback it's just not that big of
adjustment and this is the other big
thing mike people are missing about why
the shorter quarterback can work this
day and age in the nfl of course
offenses are more creative but really
it's to me
that the biggest difference is the rpos
and the read option game that has spread
defenses horizontally right mike to
where now there's passing lanes that get
stretched open to where you don't always
have to see over people it's not like
the old days where hey we're going to
condense everybody in the formation and
it's gonna be three yards and a cloud of
dust and then when we throw it we're
gonna fake three yards and a cloud of
dust and just have everybody around and
we just want you to be big and strong
and throw it through everybody or
whatever it is it's a different game and
i think because of some of those aspects
uh guys like kyla murray baker mayfield
it's just nothing anymore it's it's a
stupid point at this point the kid's got
talent he's big time uh and he showed it
again uh yesterday you know once again
and didn't need to run because i know
he's one of the fastest guys in the
draft
and and you only lose if you run right
because you run and you're fast hey he's
fast and if you run and you're not as
fast as you're supposed to be like maybe
he's not fast so smart to not run
and and look this whole thing about
height right i i keep going back to that
charlie castle dynamic from last week
that we initially thought maybe some
teams were giving him bad reports about
kylo murray's combine interviews in
order to scare the cardinals away from
taking him and this concern about height
you know anybody who's pushing this
concern about height may very well be
hoping that concerns about height will
cause calamari to fall far enough so
they can draft him the height isn't an
issue the guy can throw the guy can play
the guy is going to be one of the top
draft picks and the question is when he
gets the nfl what will he do and that
that question applies to everyone we
just don't know right and that's why
this process is so imperfect you never
know what a guy is going to do at the
next level until he gets there chris the
game changes fundamentally from your
perspective yeah when you get on an nfl
practice field for the first time right
i mean what what was the difference or
maybe even in a in a game maybe it's
even more dramatic then from what you
were used to at college yeah it's a
great that's a great question you know i
think this was probably my the biggest
thing to me you know again at the
university of texas you know i i was
throwing to some nfl receivers and tight
ends and we had an nfl running back so
it wasn't to me when i got to the nfl
first of all the mental aspect goes up
to a way another level it's a bigger
jump from college to the pros than it
was from high school to college just on
the mentality aspect of it but the
biggest thing on the field mike and i
remember feeling this in practice in day
one even forget the games is everybody
on the defense and offensive line are
just big bigger stronger more athletic i
remember dropping back the first few
times in practice and just going man it
feels claustrophobic in here you know i
was used to the speed of the db's and
watching john lynch and rondae barber
break at practice but what i wasn't used
to is everybody on the defensive line
was a freak of nature i mean he dropped
back and i had warren sapp and it was
simeon rice and you just go whoa they're
moving at a different speed to where i
didn't feel comfortable in the pocket
for a little bit and then therefore i
maybe not even as good as seeing down
the field because i'm getting used to
these bigger faster bodies around you
that would be one one of the things that
certainly jumped out to me in my you
know professional career
yeah and and as a quarterback new in the
nfl you either can deal with that or you
can't right you either have a ceiling
over your ability to adapt or you don't
and there's only one way to find out so
you know there's a chance kyla murray is
not going to end up being the next big
phenomenon in the nfl but so much is
pointing that way and the value of
having that guy i think far outweighs
the downside of rolling the dice and not
getting we've been talking about for the
past few weeks we're going to keep
talking about it right until the draft
because i want to see if the cardinals
are smart enough to do it and if they're
not who else is going to get him the
giants apparently had some folks in town
yesterday not dave gettleman he he had
you know about the clean up on aisle
three
yeah pat shurmur though was there and uh
reportedly they got together with murray
last night and you know who knows what
the giants are thinking they've talked
about the kansas city model one more
year with eli manning but with the guy
they groom uh maybe it could be kyle
murray who knows chris yeah i mean it
would be
you know kylo murray is not really their
style of quarterback the new york giants
it's been more of the prototypical guy
the phil sims the eli mannings the kerry
collins maybe kyla murray's so good time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports